what you don't know can kill you
and ultimately will because at the end
of the day all of us are going to die
and after having built two multi-figure
companies
another eight-figure company another
eight-figure company and then now we
have a portfolio of companies
that do just about a million a week i've
i've learned some things
about financial education and things
like that and i realized i was wildly
deficient
in other areas and so in this search for
meaning and figuring out
you know what i want to do when i grow
up i've kind of bucketed
the different disciplines that i think
all of us have to learn as entrepreneurs
to fill the hole that we have in our
souls and i think a lot of us
you know we we pursue business because
we feel like it is going to fill this
hole
even on some level we know it won't but
we do it anyways because we just don't
have
another best bet and so after
having enough money to question the the
meaning of life
i've kind of looked at it looked at
these at these buckets
as seven things and so that's what i'm
going to talk about in this video and i
think it's useful because
a lot of times we just don't know what
we lack and simply having
an understanding of the breadth of
topics and disciplines that we should
have and understand
will show us where our deficiencies are
and i believe that you need all seven
in order to feel more complete and as
i've made more progress in these things
i feel like i've been able to unearth my
singular meaning it's not necessarily
yours but for me it's to learn
i love learning and so for me one of the
best ways of learning
is teaching and so i get questions all
the time about why i make these videos
like
why like why would i care about doing
this stuff for free
i do it for me because i love learning
and i learn best through teaching
you know what i'm going through right
now and so these are the seven different
disciplines i think every human being
has to learn
all right so the first is um
foundational education
all right now the good thing is the
system is pretty decent at decent
at teaching this one all right so this
is like reading writing
and math like that's how i see it it's
like if you can read write and mat and
do math
you'll learn that from school and
specifically just like reading writing
yeah reading writing and math are kind
of what i would consider foundational
principles because from there you can
use reading and writing
and math to learn the rest of the
principles right and so this one's
foundational and this is pretty much the
only one that we get taught in school
which is why everyone or at least for me
i felt wildly deficient to deal with the
real world because there's so many other
things
right which is crazy to me that like
what we cover are not
i think we should just get foundations
if i were to redesign our education
system i would just teach reading
writing and math
and then the rest of it would be around
these disciplines all right so
the next thing is physical all right and
the thing is is
if you're living in this world you live
in the physical plane and so you have to
understand what you need to eat and how
do you need to move in order to
you know increase your energy longevity
etc and so all the things underneath
this is bucket energy min uh sorry uh
would be like sleep you know like your
own
sleep routines if you have them but not
to be religious about them or
superstitious about them because those
end up becoming handicaps more than they
actually end up helping you
but how to actually train to look the
way you want to look how to eat the way
you want to look how to eat
and train the way so you can know how
you want to feel all of this stuff
because you exist in this plane and we
have these bodies for our whole lives
and so it would behoove us to learn how
to do these things because
all the rest of these disciplines are no
longer a priority if your physical
health
is um is is waning right it's like
was it the there's there's a saying
about the everybody can
have every wish in the world except for
when you're sick you only have one
which is to not be sick right and so
learning this is what i would consider
the second level of education
the third level of education that i've
outlined for myself is professional
right and this is one where depending on
what your
what your skill set is right or what
sorry what what
career path you want to go down some
schools are you know if you want to be
an accountant there's pretty decent
there's a decent career path there for
you to learn that skill now most
accountants would say yeah
when i had my you know once i graduated
with my mac or my master's in accounting
that's when really my real education
began right and so
many of these are like that especially
from the formal education standpoint
but hopefully as i'm going through these
you can think to yourself like okay
where am i lacking and as i get higher
and higher up i will tell you
i think the fulfillment and the and the
meaning that you can derive from them
these kind of work like a pyramid right
like this is the base and then you you
build up
all right the next level of this uh what
i i would consider
is uh emotional all right
and uh this one you have to continue to
grow over time because this is just like
understanding your own
your own feelings and thoughts and as
you you know grow as an entrepreneur you
have to know these things because you'll
you'll figure out where your
deficiencies are all of us have them and
if you can't think to yourself
what your deficiencies are and name them
and be okay with yourself while still
having them
i think that you get stuck there because
you just don't know how to fix yourself
right
not that you need to be fixed but how to
grow right and so this is the kind of
the fourth
the fourth level of education now note
this one we don't get taught anything
about at all anywhere right and you have
to learn all this stuff on your own and
most of us
have no education on this so think about
how much time you've devoted to like
this one now because now we're really
departing from formal education
obviously there's not
much formal education around physical
recess doesn't really count right
the next level that i have here is uh
relational all right so this is how to
communicate
influence and deal with others and this
is
wildly important because first you have
to master yourself right
and then the next step there is being
able to relate to others in a way
that is that is meaningful and so by
doing that you're able to influence
others you're able to build groups build
tribes
build companies all of this is going to
be predicated on your ability to deal
with other humans
again this isn't taught anywhere right
that's why
you know some some of the books that
that were most most transformational
transformational for me in my life were
books that that talked about how to deal
with other people how to communicate
right how to how to have people like you
right how to have people trust you
and really the flip side of that is how
to be likable and how to be trustworthy
rather than some like hacks or tricks
it's so much more about the character
traits which is the ugly answer but it's
also probably the truth
so these are the these are the five
levels and if you're looking at yourself
right now hopefully you should be like
well how much time am i spending
learning uh this discipline for my own
emotions how am i
how much time am i spending learning
this discipline in learning how to
relate to others
the next one that i that i have here is
financial all right
financial literacy and uh i would say
this first in the beginning is personal
finance which is basically learning how
to spend less than you make
and then ideally significantly less than
you make if you listen to any of my
stuff
because wealth is a ratio it is not a
number it is a
it is a ratio between how much you earn
versus how much you spend so if you want
to increase your wealth you can decrease
your expenses
and in so doing become more wealthy
think about that for a second
and while you process that i will i will
tell you
the the second iteration of financial
which is then how to multiply
so in the beginning it's about the
getting getting of the money and then
the next level how to multiply the money
that you have right and have the money
work for you and that's
that's um i would say currently this is
where i'm focusing a lot of my time and
attention
because i want to learn that game that
being said
a lot of these things combined together
right like if you want to have a
business you need to know how to manage
your own emotions you need to know how
to relate to others you need to know how
to manage finances you need to have some
skills that you have
professionally to provide value to the
marketplace in and remember with like
this professional school that i was
saying earlier only if you have like a
formal
career path or you're going to learn
this in the in the in the formal
education system which is you know
failing everybody even more every every
day but
most most professions right you learn
you learn by doing you learn by getting
into that industry right
and so that's why there's no school for
entrepreneurship not really you know
there's entrepreneurship schools but
like let's be honest like they're not
legit
the the the real school for
entrepreneurship is just getting into
the game
and starting to play and so right now as
we're thinking you're going through this
right
i've named six and i'll tell you the
last one in a second um
but think about where you rate on these
like how much time am i spending
learning about financial education how
much time i spend can i read a balance
sheet right
um can i read a cash flow statement uh
relational right like how much time am i
spending learning how to relate to
others do you say things like and this
is important for everyone who has an
identity which is everyone
right do you face things like like i
don't play well with others
i don't even like saying that me
personally as i'm telling you this i
don't like saying that because i don't
like speaking that over myself
but i can tell you the more you can
become aware of how people say i am i do
i have
right i must i should etc people tell
you
their own limiting beliefs and the
things that you say and the things that
you speak
over yourself become your reality and
like this is very true
like i'm i don't want to say this like
people will say i'm not good with money
right i don't even like saying it right
because you speak this belief into
yourself and that becomes your reality
and so the first thing you have to do is
start correcting your language so that
you know it's like
i have a i have i have a weakness here i
have a deficiency in terms of my
learning
right because then it becomes an
opportunity that you can fix rather than
i
am this way it is certain i speak this
way and therefore will never grow
right and so as you're looking through
these pillars of disciplines
that that come inevitably on the on the
entrepreneurial journey
you have to you have to see what your
deficiencies are and learn them right
and that's and
if you're like looking at this and it
seems overwhelming well you have your
whole life to learn them which is what i
think is
inspiring and i honestly think for me
looking at
these disciplines has given me a lot of
meaning in my own life
because i just see this as so much stuff
that i want to do i want to learn all
this stuff
and then it makes it makes living more
interesting for me
and then finally the last one
is philosophical all right and this is
this is the values that you choose to
live by these are the things that you
believe to be true
that are eternal and so for me this has
been
incredibly incredibly useful and i can
tell you guys for anybody who's watching
this like
when you have enough money to spend
millions of dollars a year every single
year for the rest of your life just on
the money that you have
assuming it doesn't even grow like you
ask
different and weirder like life gets
weird right you have weirder questions
that you ask and then you realize
there's really
so hopefully i can jump to the end of
that for for anybody who's curious you
won't get more fulfillment from
all of these things any one of these
things but it's really
feeling how you can balance all these
things but i think that philosophical
despite the fact that i said it's the
seventh bucket i actually think that
it's the most important bucket
and all of the changes in my own
subjective well-being and how much i
enjoy living
have come from fundamental shifts in my
philosophy about
what i what i believe it means to be
human
and the time that we spend here on earth
and so
anyways if you're looking at yourself
and you're looking at your own deficits
um a and that's okay is one of my
favorite sayings
that i tell myself my own self-talk
right i'm not good at this and that's
okay
right i'm not good at this yet and
that's okay
i'm not good at the relational side with
other people yet and that's okay
right because i'm going to learn right
i'm not as good at the finances as i
would like to be
yet and that's okay right and so it
becomes it gets you out of this
defeatist talk this absolutism of being
deficient
and making it something that's an
opportunity for you to grow it and i
know this sounds minor
but i'm telling you when i look at the
employees that i have i look at the
people that are in our company i look at
the businesses that we work with
i can tell immediately by someone's
language patterns how likely they are to
grow
right and so the first thing you can do
is correct your own language patterns
for each of these
each of these buckets but getting back
to philosophical right as
the seventh bucket this bucket i believe
is i mean it's the meaning of life right
and what will happen is
if you are doing all of these things
you're doing your financial education
you're making more money you're
increasing your influence through your
relational discipline
your your s your sense of self and your
emotional management your impulse
control is improving
right your your professional skills are
enhancing
your physical well-being your energy
your sleep the habits that you have
around that are things that are
increasing your longevity increasing
your energy increasing your sense of
well-being from a physical standpoint
and hopefully you have the foundational
education of learning of reading and
writing which if you don't you should do
that first because it's the gateway to
learning all these other things
but the thing is is all of these other
ones if you don't know why you're doing
them
i think that ultimately you don't feel
better so you may improve all of these
things but you don't
feel better and i think that most of us
just want to feel better
and so for me making strides in
understanding why i do what i do and
where i derive meaning in life
has been uh one of the most fulfilling
for me
and ultimately why i've been increasing
my you know constant stuff on the
channels and
i'm writing books right now that i'll be
releasing for free for everyone
just to help other entrepreneurs um and
people
make positive contribution with the
potential that they all that we all have
inside of us and so anyways i i wish you
an absolutely amazing day
stay tuned for uh my next video um hope
you love it and uh
i'll see you in the next vid bye